in a land rover used by the queen in the
1960s william and kate had one final
official duty to carry out
after three days where they have been
under pressure to perform with so many
issues to navigate in jamaica slavery
one that he hoped he'd done enough to
address
i want to express my profound sorrow
slavery was abhorrent
and it should never have happened
in emancipation park in the middle of
kingston i met effy who comes from
trench town where the royal couple were
mobbed by crowds
so the word sorrow
from prince william is that enough no
no it's not
it's just like you're saying uh
sorry to kick you on your knee
i'm sorry that you fell
but you know you should you should
give us something more
junior runs his own cleaning business
and told me there are much more pressing
things to deal with
slavery has long gone
if we keep looking in the past
we will
never focus on the future a lot of
things to
[Music]
look at such as our economy where we're
going where we would like to be
a couple of years from now a republic do
you want to be a republican
prince william's representing the queen
and the government so there's always
only going to be so far that he can go
on matters like reparations and
apologizing but because he has this
enormous international profile there was
a huge expectation about what he was
going to say and that's why some people
that i've spoken to wonder what was the
point in the trip if it doesn't bring
any change
there have been awkward moments we are
moving on and some images that have
drawn criticism and comment the wounds
of slavery will take more than a speech
to heal a republic also won't come
quickly a referendum is needed
next stop the bahamas where some of
those issues are also still very much
alive and a new audience for the royal
couple to charm
rhiannon mills sky news in nassau the
bahamas